push on to Shana win who's one of our
stand-up we counted contributors hi and
so 0 contracts are the most common type
of employment in my area and there have
already been some measures to help
people on them but you can still turn up
for work and then there's no work there
for you so that's creating a lot of lack
of job security and which also affects
production and so what what more will
you do to protect people on zero-hour
contracts I mean maybe I'll stand up see
you the addenda but which area do you
come from them he was saying in your
area right yeah familiar zero hours
contracts are contracts that have been
abused and we've brought in regulation
for the first time I think the biggest
abuse you get is these exclusivity so
someone is on a zero-hours contract but
their company will not let them work for
any other company even though they're
not guaranteed any hours of work so a
law has now gone through Parliament
which we've introduced to stop that
happening and more generally across the
whole population around two percent of
people are on zero-hours contracts and
of course for some people they do want
that flexibility to work several people
and very their hours as possible but the
best answer i've got for people who
don't want to be in on zero-hours
contract is to try and create more
full-time jobs for people that they do
want to take and we are creating a huge
number of jobs in this country I say we
have is the businesses here who are
doing that and we've got a record number
of people in work of the Mogul reklama
women and work at the moment and so the
bit and eighty percent of those jobs are
full-time so the best thing I can do is
have an economy where business feel
confident that they want to grow and
take people on where it pays to work and
of course we increase our tax free
personal allowance now it's going up to
11,000 pounds over the next couple years
and that helps the person who doesn't
want to be on the zero-hours contract
wants that full-time job because
there'll be more opportunities in
Redditch and elsewhere contracts
actually want more
and they're most commonly to be women or
age 60 and above so we're not talking
just about my generation talking about
old people that can't get a job the only
job that they getting offered by job
center and stuff zero hour contracts
they've got no stability I can't eat
sometimes it just got no work but
suppose you don't really see that so of
course we see it in our country and I
want to I want to get rid of that and
the way you get rid of it is not again
by sort of thinking I can sit in number
11 dentistry and write some law that
stops it happening well I can do is
create an environment in which the
businesses represented here grow and
they create jobs and they they offer
that full time post to that person who
can't get the full time post at the
moment and as I say is not something
that happens overnight it happens when
you've got an economy that people have
confidence in people say you know I am
going to go out there and get myself
some more skills because I think there's
going to be a job at the end of it for
me I am a small business and I am going
to take some you know I run a small
business I am going to take someone on I
think I'm going to take that risk you
know that that dad sleep all zero hour
contracts that pushing more small paid
apprenticeships you know and internships
it's growing and your bank in the you
know cuzzo is a branding the drum about
are more people are employed than ever
before yeah but as I getting they
getting work are they getting a paycheck
are they getting stability no they're
getting a zero or contract job no
support from the benefit system even
though they're actively looking for work
you know what these are the people that
need to be more considered because then
thats related reflecting straight on to
mental health as well people who
depressed because we're only stuck in a
rut they can't find work they've got no
help in the system either so well good
more more people are getting those jobs
when people were unemployed in very
large numbers five years ago now we've
got a record number of people in work
eighty percent of those jobs are
full-time and you come from the Midlands
there's a job being created every 10
minutes in the Midlands and that's the
best answer I of course people when
economic policy fails when your economy
crashes you know the people who suffer
are precisely the people you are talking
so passionately about they are the
people the poorest in our society who
suffer and the way
you can help is by running an economy
that is stable that is growing that is
investing that is creating jobs where
businesses are expanding that is the
best possible answer to the people that
you are talking about Thank You
Chancellor